Jillian thank you now ed miliband will
use a speech today to accuse the
government of ignoring a million young
people who've fallen off the voting
register because of the way changes
changes to the way people sign up now
the labor leader says David camera then
Nick Clegg a short changing the future
of hundreds of thousands of people well
here at Sky News were giving young
people the chance to have their say on
politics without stand up be counted
form let's talk to two of those taking
part Danny Bartlett and Michael Adams
morning to you both and what do you make
of what Ed Miliband is saying is a
general premise and the idea that young
people are being ignored if they're
being left out of the equation a little
bit Danny yeah I mean they're this only
been ignored I mean that Sam I mean 7.3
million young people in the country and
I think a lot largely most of them
unrepresented at that higher political
level but I think that the the million
voters left out that he's equated to I
mean the old electoral system register
system didn't work last time when it was
the head of the household registering
voters it's not about these 1 million
people it's about political literacy in
our country which is appalling and I
think that's in Eva what's in an even
worse state is political education
within schools the reason why a lot of
these people are apathetic is because
they've not been giving that political
literacy those lessons in how to be an
informed active citizen and I think that
that's really the core of the issue how
difficult is it Ben Michael for you then
under those circumstances to get
involved in politics because certainly
what we've seen with stand-up you
counted is if I see a lot of young
people like yourself actually want to
get involved want to show their interest
and have their sake I think lots of
young people have their own views their
own opinions I think that's where social
media is such a big thing now is because
people can sort of just instantly put
our views out there and that's what
politics is it's your view on an issue
and I think a lot of people have these
views but they feel disengaged by major
pies and I think with this sort of
education system that we're talking
about it's about giving people than
understanding of what they actually
think about politics and how they can
affect it so Danny you think that that
young people simply on
formed enough but they don't know enough
about the issues but they do actually
want to know yeah there's so many people
out there I mean we were talking in the
Kremlin run about how many people that
they have a relationship with politics
you don't actually mention the word
politics and actually you say well
what's wrong with society now start
really getting passionate about it but
the problem is that last year for
example less than a hundred thousand
young people took the citizenship
education lesson which is the only
lesson on the national curriculum that
actually teaches the fundamentals of how
to be an informed citizen and and the
problem is that it's not statutory so
they don't have to do it and that's the
biggest issue if you're not being
politicized at home or between your
friends where are you going to get your
political education from its it better
is it beneficial being a political
target in the way that obviously the
Labour Party is trying to establish
today with it with the voter
registration system does it help you
Michael thinking that you are at least
in the focus of political leaders I
think last election we all felt were in
the focus with student tuition fees EMA
conservatives were very keen on keeping
which we both seemed sort of just gone I
think in a recession it's always you
know there's going to be cuts but you
would hope that some of the main
principles that they got to get young
people's votes would be kept in and I
think we felt very sidetracked so it's
very hard to trust what most political
figures are saying we have to take
everything with a pinch of salt as in
most electorates but I think with the
individual registration i think his
grievances not that there is individual
registration because it was a labor
policy as well but it got brought in and
there was no sort of plan to make
schools do it like in northern ireland
schools have a mess of responsibility to
make sure their pupils register to vote
and it gives you that sort of gateway
when you're talking about which
registration to then talk about wider
politics and what politics actually is
and what about lowering the voting age
are you both in favor of that or not um
i doing anything to get young people
involved but again it goes back to
education you could lower the voting age
to 16 but if they still don't know how
to be an informed citizens if they still
don't know how to create impact what is
the point it needs to go hand in hand
you know if you lower the voting age you
need to improve political literacy in
and citizenship I wonder it because a
lot of people now obviously a lot of pee
in their 30s 40s 50s 60s don't bother to
turn out and vote spare me particularly
in local elections how important is it
going to be for you to this year looking
forward to the general election actually
thinking do you know what I am going to
get involved in this I am we on whatever
the outcome turns out to me i'm going to
make sure my voice is heard I think
definitely this year I really want to
get involved and get other young people
involved things like februari fifth
there's national voter registration day
I think that would be very big for young
people because a lot young people
haven't registered themselves before so
be the first on the register themselves
from head of household so I think things
like that and I think one of the things
that will look at as young people is
what parties are actually just trying to
get us engaged and registered and what
parties are just saying right for us
because I think that made a big
difference in the Scottish referendum is
a lot of people even if they didn't vote
yes they'll saying stand up be counted
look these people are actually getting
us registered and they seem much more
genuine and some people were persuaded
by that let's remember as well that
voting is all politics is more than just
voting you know what would you rather
have a young person engaged in their
communities giving money to charity
petitioning or someone that sits on
their hands and every four years you
know submits a ballot paper so I think
that we people need to be educated on
you know obviously we want more people
voting but at the same time there is a
lot more to politics than just that I
think you two could be running the
company hey you're talking brilliant
love like guys thank you very much great
to talk to if you want to get involved
yourself you can do of course go to Sky
News and calm stand up be counted it's a
see on twitter at sky su bc i mean it's
it's all there for you get in touch get
involved and let us know what you think
and all the blogs and things that you
post on the website will let you put
them all out on twitter as well so you
can see what other people think in your
same age group and it's all good stuff
as well as you saw